starting in just a moment
one moment please
all right thank you for being patient
and we'll begin
our digital marketing master class
on successfully managing accounts inside
the google's black
box with brad guettis the ppc chair of
simply learn
he is also a co-founder of ad alice's
and an author of several books including
advanced google adwords
and i'm stuart creek i'm a marketing
manager here at simply learn
i'll be in the background
helping brad and
how to participate in the webinar a
couple of items about the webex controls
please put your questions for brad into
the q a function
and we will um gather those up and
ask him the questions at the end of the
webinar in the q
a segment you can put information in the
chat box if you do make sure it goes to
host and presenter
all panelists is better because when you
send it to all panelists we will all see
it
otherwise if it's host only it goes to
me and brad won't see it
again questions asked in the chat box
will be answered toward the end of the
webinar
in the q a so it's best to put your
questions in q a
and we are going to be doing several
polls
one at the beginning and one at the end
so i'd like to begin with
this one and it's basically just to get
a feel for who's in our audience today
and i'd like to ask how people are
coping
we've been asking this for the duration
of the pandemic
things keep getting better and worse in
cycles so
you like to get a gauge for your state
of mind
and we'll keep the poll open for about
another 15 seconds
and it'll close in three two
one
and see the poll results
and so we have an audience that's
uh kind of most of the people
are two extremes whether it's the more
than 10 years experience or they're
still in college
and the rest of you are kind of
distributed in between
that'll help her add the gauge
this presentation and it's good to see
that
um almost everybody is feeling well or
doing okay
um for those of you who
are a little down we hope that
getting this information from an expert
will
uh help improve your moods today so with
that i'm going to clear this
and introduce brad
as i mentioned brad is the ppc chair
pay-per-click
marketing chair at simply learn
co-founder
of his uh on agency analysis
and uh
actually an automatic ad testing
platform
author of advanced google adwords and he
is a well-known
writer speaker and commentator as well
as educator
in google ads
account management and pay-per-click
advertising so we're very
pleased to have him here i'm going to
stop sharing my screen and allow him to
share his so that he can
present to you and welcome brett
nope you're on mute
i have the ability to share yet i think
you need to make me something
there you are all right
and let's share this screen
just to confirm you can see everything
yes
all right and let me just move all the
go to meeting stuff
oh with there we go over here so i can
see anything that needs i need to see
all right hello
the new control panel is a little iffy
all right so whatever anyway everyone
so um today we're gonna really sort of
look at managing accounts in google's
black box
for those of you who've been in those
ten plus years like myself
at one point in time the world was
manual everything you did
you calculated bids in excel um
you you had to go manually crawl through
everything and more and more has been
automated
but this doesn't mean you can't be
successful
what it often means is we're sort of
steering through the automation
and making our decisions on sort of how
we want things to go
so we can very much liken this to a lot
of the self-driving cars these days
right we hop in and we tell google where
do you want to go
kind of like our conversion story right
what's our desired speed
like our bidding um how long should we
stay on the road right our budget
and we give it some parameters right
don't take toll roads stay in this
region
and we kind of sit back and see what
happens
but that's a myopic right your single
view
now when we want a bigger look we kind
of want to know
what's someone else doing right is
everyone using the exact same technology
then
things seem really really ordered
but they're not and this is due to
people people are highly irrational
and computers of course are very
rational they're logical things right
they get inputs outputs and they
you know they don't make contextual
decisions about what they see
and so often we want to look at is how
do we
deal with the irrational humans right in
the context
of a logical marketing system and and
this is where we've looked this a couple
times but it's always good for those who
haven't seen this to to walk through
why we sort of make these statements
right so this was
a study done where a brand
took monkeys that were the dominant
monkey
the subordinate and the purina which is
a sexy monkey
and they put pictures of the monkeys and
brands
next to three buckets of food and the
monkey walked up they hit a button they
got food out
now as sort of expected right the the
monkey
the sexy monkey got the most people
clicking on it getting food
then the dominant then the subordinate
was by far the least
and after a while they removed the
monkeys and left the brand names up
the brains that were next to the sexy
monkey got the most clicks still for
food the dominant second the subordinate
third
and even we examine this to humans and
how we behave in marketing
it's the same now computers are the
opposite
they would say no no that subordinate
monkey line is the
shortest since the result is the exact
same
i should take that pathway and so
the computer would go subordinate
dominant purina
in their choices the opposite of a human
right
and this is where people can be
illogical
and often humans have what we call
prior knowledge where we can make
intuitive guesses to things
so this was you know a a video game a
16-bit video game for what we'd see back
in the 80s
and with this video game they gave it to
humans and they gave it to machine
learning systems
and they said complete this level well
humans go okay i jump over this
i don't hit the monster i climb down a
ladder and and they won in about a
minute
part of this game though of what you
don't see in the front end is that you
don't get
any feedback about how close you get to
the ending until you finish it
every single machine learning system
except one
failed to complete a level and the one
that finished
took 37 hours of gameplay
humans one minute they changed the
texture
all right so humans now boy this was
tougher for humans to figure out
this took about five minutes for humans
to do again
games couldn't figure it out our machine
learning couldn't figure it out
then it was changed to every time you
successfully got closer to
the destination you got a feedback loop
right a positive input
machines could figure it out very very
quickly and beat humans
right early on though when there's a
lack of knowledge and
input humans outperform machines
they use prior knowledge when there's a
lot of information
machines outperformed humans that's
often
something you need to sort of bring to
the table is that prior experience
you have about the world and how humans
think
the other thing humans add is context
to what the data looks like
so if i made this statement if
mcdonald's has a really good year and
more people eat
hamburgers then you realize more people
will die by lightning
or maybe it's reversed more people die
by lightning therefore we go eat more
hamburgers
now this makes no sense right no sense
at all
however right this is really correlated
data over a 10 year period of time
and this is where humans add context to
that as saying
no that correlation doesn't matter
ignore this data or this
does matter right and this leads us to a
quote i've used a few times an important
quote
that automation is really really
important right but excessive automation
is often a mistake i mean even tesla has
pulled back some to say
humans are underrated so the question
really becomes right
if everyone's got the same tech how do
you stand out
what do you do right how do you go
around everyone and that's we're going
to
talk about today is getting around
everything and
sort of making your own pathway when
everyone uses the same marketing stack
in this case
mostly you know google you can re-share
your screen
brad i should have stopped sharing yeah
i hit it
all right there we go it shared
sorry about that no worries no worries
okay
so we're going to start with bidding
because this is usually
when people think automation they start
bidding so the number one thing is
what are you tracking right so if
you want to track in-store and chat and
phone calls and your website
right you need to make sure google can
read all that that's step one
right if you only give the machine half
the data it makes half a good
decision secondly do you
want to track everything right so
if you give it the data and say this is
a goal the machine is going to use it
we've seen e-commerce sites who add
phone call tracking thinking
maybe take some phone orders and see
their conversions drop
because the machine said oh hey look we
can get your phone calls really cheap
and most of the phone calls are actually
for
things like returns and so forth hey
stuart you're not on mute though so we
can also hear you fyi
um and so right this is why you want to
make sure
right that you're tracking things
appropriate so
google has changed conversion tracking a
bit on the back end
where if you go into your conversions
right you can see
you can say i want to track this but i
don't want it used for automation
you've got a conversion column use
automated bidding
and all conversions all conversions are
really for you
then we need to make thoughts about if
you have a physical store
should we use in-store visits it's a
great metric
but what about driving directions is
that really an
intent we want to track and so going
through
all the possible conversions in giving
them
either proper values or tracking or not
tracking them
is a really important part of making
sure the machine has the right
data are you b2b
and your your tracking takes six months
to happen
well you need to make proxies for
conversions to have the machine work
from
and so what we talked about often in a
paid search right is that
we have all this data everything's so
transparent and you find out it's a
giant lie
because every system has different
business rules for tracking stuff
so we often talk about our source of
truth
right our source of truth is the
seo department can't use one set of data
the ppc a different set
the social a different set the email
different set because we can all make
our data look amazing
and if your cmo whoever adds up all the
leads you claim to drive
it's like five times more than the
company actually made in revenue
so what you really want is to be
consistently lied to right where yes we
under report five percent but we
consistently under report five percent
or
we consistently over report ten percent
whatever it is
in that way your trending is better and
you're all using the same data set
for machine learning because while you
think you're using a paid search
the email team is using it to send
emails and subject lines
everyone's using ai to some extent here
now lastly when we think about our
conversion data because with
automated bidding we're telling the
system here's our conversion data
do this right either way a cpa bid
a robust bid what not but what if
someone
clicks three times to convert right so
if your last click which is default the
first two clicks are completely ignored
which means over time they get bid to
zero because they're not converting
right lastly if we say oh no give only
all the credit to everyone who first
how they discovered us which is first
click
then you never close a deal so thinking
through your attribution model
is not only for you to understand
how people find us how we divvy up
credit when someone does multiple clicks
it's also about the machine bidding
because you decide how you want to get
the machine data to make
its decisions you've got data driven
meaning let the machine figure out what
it thinks is the best
um for for bidding for the most
conversions for you
but if you don't have much data it's
actually linear right we have things
like time decay give more credit to the
last click
but this is such an important decision
to make
because if you're using automated
bidding you're telling the system
if someone clicks four times before they
buy
this is how you divvy up the credit for
those clicks
meaning this is the input the machine
takes
and when deciding how to bid so
attribution is important and we've done
you know webinars on attribution
but when you're giving your entire
bidding to a black box
the way you track conversions and then
divvy up
conversions can make a huge difference
if you have two companies
that are identical in every aspect
but one is using a position based bid
system
and one uses a last click bid system
they will get
completely different results over time
and then this
is this is such an important sentence
but it must be made it's a very
important one with automated bidding
so you know bidding should be automated
brad quick quick question you use the
terms cpa and ross could you
just define those for the oh sure cpa is
cost per action
or cost per conversion but usually when
you say cpc we mean cost per click so
it's how much you pay for a conversion
and roast is return on ad spend
how much do you make based upon what you
spend thank you
so bidding should be automated right but
that doesn't mean you're always using
google's technology so for instance we
have a company we work with
who sells electric fireplaces so
a forecast of snow in the south where it
doesn't snow very often
increases conversion rates we have
another company they do a lot of tv
tv advertising right so conversion rates
increase within 30 minutes of a tv
commercial airing
right we'll all see other people
conversion rates decrease if a term is
misspelled
common in medical industry so
when you see right you see these
insights in your data
one of your questions is a
does google take this into account for
how they do bidding
right that's that's a that's a one
question uh
two if you're doing automated bidding it
doesn't tell you this stuff you don't
pull the insights from this which is why
you often get into data science where
you
learn these insights so these are true
statements
but just because you're doing automated
bidding
doesn't mean you'll always use google's
or you may divvy up google's bidding
so for instance this campaign sells
electric fireplaces this company
and then northeast of the united states
right most people have fireplaces built
in they don't make many sales
so they don't have enough data to return
our ad spend bidding
so they do cpa bidding though they split
up the campaigns they have campaigns in
the south
right they have mostly sales in the
southern part of the united states
therefore they do
return our aspen bidding there then they
keep the special campaign
it's gonna snow in insert city name
dallas phoenix what not
right cozy up to electric fireplace this
weekend
and that's manual because it doesn't
learn data it's never consistently on
so here we're using google's automated
bidding
but based upon what we know of how
people react
we're saying google use your black box
cpa here
your other black box draw us here and
then we're going to manually handle
these over here
so you can divvy up and mix and match
even the automated bid systems
now in this case different company
they're a a call center they have about
a hundred call
call reps for them it's
they consider it cheaper to pay for more
clicks that do not convert
than to pay the salary of someone who's
not on the phone
right and they know that if someone
waits more than five seconds
25 hang up 30 seconds 30 hang up so not
a big difference
but at a minute right 50 hang up so
they know in real time their average
wait time number of reps on a call
number of reps available to answer
google doesn't know this
right so they have data google doesn't
have
about bidding so they don't want to use
google's automated bidding in fact
they bid by a script right that just
says
if three reps are open there's no wait
time increased bid modifiers
if one of three apps are open increase a
little bit if
no one's available start decreasing bids
it's not super complicated right it's
not nearly as complicated as google's
machine learning is
but because they're working with data in
real time google will never have access
to
they are better at bidding even if it's
a simple script
so there are times that you want to
still use quote the manual bid settings
even though you're not manually bidding
you're just doing a different system to
set the bits
so this is where you know we can we can
mix and match these so it's not an all
or nothing proposition
then what's also important and so a
couple years ago right if we had
issues where conversion tracking was
broken for a couple of days
we'd have to start from scratch
rebuilding up our data
right so what's important is google has
launched exclusions where we can say
ignore this date range
in our bidding which is really good
or we expect a change to conversion
rates
um in this time frame so anticipate that
now google can't anticipate changes yet
they don't do a
lot of year over year anticipation of
changes
but this year a valentine's day which
was a
historically a day everyone went to
manual bidding because google just
couldn't keep up with the volume changes
this year google did pretty well and so
we're seeing
the machine finally get enough data to
manage some of the volatile days
black friday was one of their best
managed now a lot of people still go to
manual on black friday because there's
inventory considerations google doesn't
know
so those are some things to keep in mind
with using black boxes for
bid purposes now things like audiences
though
give you more information right so with
bid modifiers google ignores
most bid modifiers with automated
bidding
audiences though this little adjust
priority
is is an important consideration so
if you have an audience and you're like
we know this audience converts better
right than these other audiences you can
add the audience
you can give it a positive bid modifier
now google won't use your actual bid
modifier but they
realize you said this one's actually
more important so we're going to
prioritize this and how we set bits
or you could do negatives for that so
this is where you can start to give more
signals to the machine it doesn't use
them in an
absolute value of changing your bids
around
but it is giving more input suggestions
to the machine
and it's this type of stuff that you
should keep
your eye on of what google's going to
start using
so that we can bring in more of our own
data to help feed the machine stuff
custom
for us and this has always been sort of
the issue over time is
google would never they don't make a bid
system for you
they make a system for everyone and then
you have to find ways of how to
customize your data right audiences and
the conversions you give it in your
attribution
are some of the best ways to do that now
you can give the machine even additional
signals right if you're
legion but you want to use return ad
spin bidding
you can give it even points and say
sales a thousand points it calls 250
it aggregates your data and then can
even do some robust bidding
off of different types of leads so this
is where
if you're if you were to just say we're
going to use cost per action bidding
google doesn't differentiate
a sale to a chat right they think it's
the same thing it's a lead
in their mind you gave it one conversion
but if you give it sort of points as
sort of proxies for dollars
and then you use return on ad spend
bidding it does start to prioritize
these so again we can make the system
work for us
so there are people who are doing
in-house bidding
and and where you see this mostly is
larger
enterprise companies who have incredible
data sets
right and if you look those in the end
they're doing
predictive analytic modeling so they're
looking at historical data
their trend changes across
all their audience information in
predicting the changes to conversion
rates so they can set appropriate bids
based upon what people will be doing in
the future
google can't do this for you because
this is super super custom
so there are are companies though who do
true quote manual bidding from google
side it's not it's automated with their
own tech stack
this is the extreme if you're a massive
company
this is something to think about if you
are
don't have a couple million dollars
literally to
build a system then you're gonna get
better results with google
which is why a lot of people say like
why does google want you to use their
automated bidding
you know because a auction control if
they can control the auction they make
more money
but in reality they're better at bidding
than just most of google manager
google ad managers are bidding is a lot
of math and the
other thing is opportunity cost
if you were to go back to how we manage
bids
you know 15 years ago and we would sit
down with excel spreadsheets
and we might spend an entire day just
changing
bids for the next week well okay at that
point in time
you lost a day to changing a number
that has a lifespan a good lifespan
of until the time you change the number
again right
bid's only good until you change the bid
again so it's more like a lot of wasted
time
where if you say how do we do ad
testing to consider how people are
reacting these days
with the state of the openness versus
safety versus everything else
and let's do that ad test that's
that change is going to last you a much
longer time you'll get better results
from that than just changing some bids
around
and this is why given the bits of the
black box
a black box could be yours right is
often a good idea
if you're steering the machine properly
they'll be on bidding the next thing we
really look at black box
is keywords and last webinar if you
haven't seen it
we really went through the match type
changes so the exact match the phrase
match
how to figure out moving modified broad
to the old match type so that's
archive for you um to watch but we went
through those
in detail now we could truly automate
great
keywords we could say dynamic search ads
we give google parts to our website
we kind of write part of the ad we sit
back and do nothing
these this is where intense
user intent google has not fully figured
out
you as a human are much better at
deciphering intent than google is
so well you could do things like this
um it would automate everything right
you could do dsas
plus cpa bidding and you're technically
done um you wouldn't get good results
because
you're giving the computer almost too
much leeway
and where it doesn't know how to go in
certain areas
so we really think about keywords and we
say okay we've got this term
and google says ah thank you for this
term we think it means all this other
stuff
and you're like no it means about this
much stuff
so we think of a search from sonic the
queen right it says
this is where you start from but then we
need to use
audiences and negative keywords to say
this is
really how far you can come back and
forth
and as match types become looser and
sort of intent based
where your intent and google's honestly
the same thing
we get in this sort of world we say all
right here is
right an exact to a variant to a phrase
and these are the possibilities and then
we say nope google negative keywords
you can't touch this area nope this is
negative we don't want this group
and this group isn't as good so we'll do
audiences negative modifiers these are
just priority
lowers right how google will show that
then we have positive modifiers and
audiences telling google
hey these you know reach and we can do
demographics and so forth
and so we're essentially right taking
these
search terms and we're giving google the
guard rails to say
this is how far you can go right here's
elasticity
you can stay in this range but you can't
wander further out
and this is a lot of how you work or
you're picking the keywords
with a machine that wants to expand
where it shows
so you are designing right sort of the
road it can travel on and putting those
guardrails in place
because the problem we get into is the
machine doesn't know how to pick
intent so if we've got
multiple ad groups that can match the
same search term right
then what we'll often see is the machine
says hey these two search terms both
match
so i'm going to sort of show them both
and in this first example here
when it's shown from ad group 1 we have
a 34
conversion rate ad group 2 25 percent
on the bottom we have ad group
conversion rates range from 18 to 32
percent
huge ranges so this is again where the
machines is going to go back and forth
say can i figure this out
you as a human says i can see the
pattern right here
stop showing it here show it from over
here right and that's part of your job
is to
audit the machine so we went through
engrams quite a bit last week or last
month too but
the end grams right with the machine
learning google
expands your queries to what they deem
as relevant
google doesn't show you for as many
queries these days doesn't show you all
your sorry doesn't show
your search term data for all your
queries these days so you have less data
to work with
since you have less data to work with
you need to find new ways to examine
this
right ngrams is a good one where we can
start to see
what is the pattern across data for
instance this is the the search terms
for the word
keyword plus quote right and it's just a
two word word
um now that sounds exact match word
it's a keyword of the name quote so how
far could google really match this to
turns out we've seen more than 50
variations of
eight word search terms for a three word
exact match term
right and but if you look at the data
would you really go read things that are
16 clicks seven clicks five clicks
eleven clicks it's so low
you don't feel you have enough to make
decisions
now if we were to say well let's just do
an engram
all right so now we look at the patterns
across queries
and then we aggregate the data so now we
can say
when someone searches with the word how
our cost per conversion is over a
thousand dollars
um this account by the way is around 300
350 cpa so if someone asks a question
our cpa is three times higher than if
they do not ask a question
there's enough data here a machine
should have figured this out i mean
we're talking
over a million dollars spent right in
three months on the word how
but google hasn't plugged on the machine
to look for these patterns
so it's not using it so this is where
you again look at the data and say
okay the machine missed this we need to
make this a negative keyword right and
then you would say oh well this is how
what about the other question words
and so the human is still very much
needed
to find the gaps in the machine machines
are not omniscient right they don't see
everything so your job is to check for
those gaps and fill them in and sell our
machine
you messed up here right we need to plug
these spots
so we think about where to stand out
from the automation right the number one
place
is ads ads are when we look we look at a
lot of accounts and
if there's a place that the majority of
accounts don't do
well it's writing ads um ads
you have to think through what does
someone want
what is this ad group trying to do what
is this page about
how do we combine these together how do
we make this unique from ad group 2 and
they want to slightly
different products with service so a lot
of people don't get ads right and so
they sort of turn to rsas and say hey
here's a bunch of responsive search ads
rsas where you give google a lot of
lines
and they say we'll figure out how to
make these ads work for you
and when that happens we're relying on
google to understand
user intent and how
users behave this gets us right back
to earlier that's in the day of the sexy
monkey
and the eating beef causes lightning
strikes and so forth
it doesn't understand humans and so we
often
see is that when you add a responsive
search ad to an ad group
right google loves serving them they
google believes in responsive search ads
they often win by conversion per
impression or sorry they offer my ctr
click-through rate um they often lose by
other metrics
and we'll often see is google serves
them by far the most
now again this is where you as a human
say our goal is conversions
and google is by far showing
right the most of our ad that gets the
least amount of conversion so we need to
pause that or change the inputs right
because the machines inherently favor
rsas you need to again watch that to put
guard rails
now part of the reason
the way they're designed so when
when we look at what combinations of
features and benefits result
in the best conversion compression the
best results
it's usually mixing and matching calls
to action
what do you want someone to do with
benefits what does it do for them
when you give a machine a bunch of ad
lines a it doesn't know
right that this is a benefit this is a
feature and this is how we persuade a
user
he just has to do all these combinations
to try to figure it out
you inherently know the difference which
is why
if there's a place that humans often
and i mean really often and probably
most of the time beat machines
it's in creating good ads um it's it's
the writing part humans are much more
creative than machine is
and so when you think of how do we stand
out when everyone uses the same tech
it's often really in that ad part i mean
this is
um last year when we first had lockdowns
and things got
got bad right this company schools close
lockdowns were announced they paused
their account like many people
they brought their old ads back they
didn't do too well competitors enabled
ads
and that helped a little bit because
there's more people saying the same
thing
and then they went oh what do people
really want these days
to know how to stay safe and what we're
doing to keep our employees safe
boom they changed ads based upon that
simple statement
and they had and they're a like
25 30 and a 35 year old company their
absolute best year
ever was last year right because
they learned how to talk to customers
and listen to customers
so while this is old on those of you who
are in college right this is something
beaten into you
customers always right listen to
customers it's
true but often in digital marketing
you've got
you hear and then you've got a wall of
various fulfillments and things and then
customers and you often don't hear
direct to the customers
right and this is often where you may
want to talk to the sales people or
if you're a physical company going right
along whatever it is right to learn what
the customers really want
because marketing hasn't changed right
it's persuading a
user to take action um claude hopkins
wrote a book 90 years ago on scientific
advertising
a lot of it's still relevant today and
so
under getting your insights from ads is
really important
so this is where we often even turn to
multi-aggregate testing where we're
aggregating data across ad groups if
this is a new concept to you
um we've also done webinars on this
that's in the simpler archive
right we're essentially saying we have
this
question um does keyword insertion
um affect my data right which is this
very bottom test here
so we've got you know over
5000 ad groups where we have keyword
don't have keyword insertion and 4000
with keyword insertion
just aggregating data right to
understand the difference
and this is where you as a human can
learn those good insight stuff from
subject lines for email to button so
forth right so when we think about tests
we've seen lately we do a lot of tests
right
we've seen large brains finding better
conversion rates not including brand for
non-brand keywords which is pretty
common
we've also seen a large brand finding
better conversion rates including brand
for non-brand keywords
i put these two first right they found
the exact opposites
one of them's in travel um they're a big
travel aggregator company
and people want not they don't care what
your name is they want good deals on
travel
the other one's an insurance company
there's a a lot of
brand knowledge and insurance right so
they find the exact different things so
often when you hear someone say
yeah always do this or always do that
you should hear like this is something
we should test to see how it affects our
data
because we may be different we may be
the exception
and as a human right
marketing advertising and connecting
with other humans
is something you are way better equipped
to the machine is
right and so when we think about this
all this automation going on
handing the bidding to the computer with
the proper
inputs right useful making sure the
computer's showing you for the right
things right your keywords the intent is
important and you're gonna
leverage both well you might use
responsive search ads
it's fine to use them and test them
right that's always great to test
in the end though what that communicates
to a user
right is that last connection point of
what makes paid search powerful right
paid search to someone saying
i want x i go to google i said i want x
and your job is to say i have x i'm
really good at x you can find lots of
great information about x here
come to our site and buy x or learn
about x right that's
that's your job right and so that's
where that human
really comes in and you know we've seen
now uplifting and positive messages
are are often beating that we're here
for you in the unpredicted
unprecedented times those are failing
right now
and you know the safety and what you did
to keep employees safe
are still doing well they're trending a
little bit down
we will see with delta another month if
those trend back up again this is what
we're actually watching really closely
is the uplifting and positive messages
versus the safety messages and where
everyone sits these are iffy right now
is sort of things have been a little
crazy the past month um
humor and colorful are really doing well
because people have been locked up in a
way and yes some of you have gotten out
luckily and
and seen stuff but that human a humor
and colorful
is doing well as we've seen so much gray
seeing any little you know yellow and
orange and something else is really
pulling people out
and that freedom and sort of escape
through people is starting to do well
and
doing exceptionally well in certain
regions
and this is why the ad part these are
humanistic trends the machines don't get
this at all
right and this is really if i'm stressed
enough or that humans really really live
so we think about the future right
number one when we say
attribution we're often talking in
channel these days meaning
what happens if you click a google ad a
facebook ad an amazon ad and then you
just search organically and buy right so
in google's attribution you only had one
click
because it sort of doesn't see all these
other things
so across channel attribution system is
what we eventually have to go to
but this is the other problem is
everyone's got their own machine
learning
so we have this is an actual client's
data right
where their email machine says send
emails tuesday afternoon
their tv says these channels at nine
except when football games are on
because they sponsor several football
stadiums
right so then you should do stuff on
saturday afternoon
but google says the conversions are best
for you on weekdays from three to five
and then of course their dsp is
optimizing on images
that aren't in their tv ads or their
google discovery ads
so every system is giving them
different data and there's this is where
the human still right now has to say
hold on let's put let's make sure that
someone who is
seeing our tv ad and searching is
actually seeing the benefits smart tv
commercial
right and and that's still this is the
role of humans because there's not
any really cross channel
machine learning stuff going on this is
your your business intelligence
is very important in this we think of
what makes black boxes useful right
we've got
centralized data which some of you
probably have
we have coordinated data which some
people have
pulling insights and attribution from
that
some people have it but it's pretty low
predicting what's going to happen based
upon our current data sets
this is where the truly cutting-edge
companies are living
it's it's tough going right now this is
still pretty new territory
but that's where we will be is using
centralized data
and year over year and other data
sources right bringing it in
to predict user experience on that it's
a tough world still there
that that's the real cutting edge not
many people their stuff
for most companies working on a
centralized data hub
with coordinating data across systems is
a great place to start
um it's it's not done in a lot of places
still
because in reality look at this right
it's all data right i mean the
self-driving car goes out it gets inputs
everywhere
so that doesn't matter do you think your
self-driving car
cares about the wind speed on the top of
the trees
when that's 40 feet above where it sits
no doesn't matter it's data doesn't make
a difference to you
it won't affect you in any way right so
some of this data does matter that yield
sign
that's very important data those
pedestrians that you're about to hit
very important data
right the fact that there is someone
waiting over here doesn't matter at all
so iphone what we have to look at right
is this
is the data we need to focus on and
learn from and make our decisions on
this is the noise right that sometimes
we have to tell google
ignore the noise right ignore these
keywords ignore this stuff they don't
matter
this is where you focus we can get there
and so as google's black box will expand
in more regions
right your job is a just to make sure it
has the data to work with
right it's working with the conversions
you want the attribution you want you're
pulling data from that right that's your
step one
two you give it guardrails on the
targeting
be it keywords audiences what not right
and say
this is the type of user we want
going to keep expanding how they do the
targeting so you
need to keep saying okay this is extra
noise ignore it right this is where you
get to roam
as you're going um and and then finally
when it comes to the message right
why does someone want to do business
with you
this is where you truly shine
um and can make the big difference in
how you look at stuff and so that's as
we look at google's black box those are
sort of the three
areas and where you need to really be
focused
versus you can give the machine some
leeway
all right and with that i'm going to
stop for a moment and see what kinds
of questions and everything um
we have for so far today so
stewart hopefully we have some uh good
questions
thoughts etc from from today's session
we certainly do um
our first basic question uh definitional
from a girish in the youtube live
audience what is the black box what's
the
the definition of google's black box uh
you know what so
black box is really a term that's been
used gosh since
50 to 60 years to say something that
makes decisions with you not knowing why
it makes decisions
it's sort of a jargon term that's been
around for i don't know 100 years i
don't even know where it comes from
uh the etymology of black box there was
a novel
called gravity's rainbow by thomas
pinchon
that referred to a black box i think
that may be the first uh
first reference to it yeah but it's just
sort of a very nebulous term that's
existed for years
of something that is making decisions
that you aren't privy to why it makes
decisions and it affects you in the end
right um in google's case that would be
you know why is it deciding what bids to
make and that type of thing
yep okay um
we have a
question that relates to broad match
modifier
nikki asks
whether the the changes to broad batch
modifier
are going to be addressed in
the simply learn digital marketing
masters course
oh uh great question
um i have i hope so i have not heard
from the
program managers yet so i hope so but
the web it for now
the webinar we did last last month
um covers everything you need to know
about the modified broadband changes
we went through it in depth of changes
how to make them etc
yeah i dropped the link to that into the
q
a and i will drop it also into the chat
so that people can go unfortunately we
didn't record that on
youtube live so the link is to a
linkedin live recording that is
a little bit lower quality
but it does have all of brad's
information from that webinar so
that's in the chat now um
durba asks how can waiting time be
synced with
google ad scripts does this happen
within 24 hours
how can waiting time so in their case
they their phone system right
has wait times aggregated in it
and so they're just using their phone
system their ivr
um their their phone system data
to look at waiting times and then their
computer just pulls it out and then
aggregates it and uses it for for google
data changes
google doesn't know your wait times
right so this is something you need to
pull from your phone data systems
um if you're using uh one of the more
complex systems
then you probably have it somewhere it's
a matter of of aggregating it together
okay uh
alain asks uh for in-house bidding do
you need to use an api
um technically no um you can use uh
scripts
um as well so we see some companies
who are keeping information in scripts
and they
have um they'll have like you know a web
hook
in their ecommerce system that is
pushing out to a script in google docs
which then runs
sorry updates data in google docs and
then
a script that runs in google ads is
pulling data from google docs to change
their bids and stuff based upon their
web hook stuff
so you need to coordinate that to some
extent um
and and some people were on a simple
script that just says based upon
conversion rates over the past you know
90 days
how should my bits be changed and use a
very simple you know
ctr divided by uh cpa formula
um so you don't have to you could use
scripts
api for in-house bidding um or
you know or you could do it in other
other ways to do it as well
okay um we have a couple of definitional
questions
um and i know that the last webinar you
did
addressed this one what's an engram ah
so you know what is my screen still up
stuart
i know but i can let you share again can
you share my screen real quick
yeah let me share my screen real quick
all right so these search terms right so
we look at this this search term we have
how and the term how has been one two
three
four five six queries
we have the term how much the term how
much is in one two
three four queries all right five six
queries
right and so what we're doing engram
does is it's looking at
commonalities of words across search
queries
then it's aggregating data by each of
these now if you're a statistician by
the way
technically an n-gram is one a bigram is
two combinations that trigram is three
we're marketers we sort of don't always
use all the perfect statistician data
um and so the n-gram is trying to do is
say
when the word how is anywhere in these
queries
then what is my aggregate data to make
decisions to pull insights
so that's really what the engram bi-gram
trigram type of data is doing
okay you can have the screen again all
right
and then we have you know a couple of uh
standard terms if you could just uh
define rsa
eta ctr that type of thing sure so
rsa is responsive search ads so these
are the ad formats that you give
google between three and eight headlines
you give google
two to six descriptions or something it
combines them back and forth as they
show as the user so you don't know
what the user is going to see eta
stands for expanded text ad which is now
the standard text that format
where you you create three headlines and
um two descriptions and then you know
exactly what the user is going to see
ctr is click-through rate which is the
ratio of
how often someone sees your ad versus
clicks on your ad
um and then yoshi asked if you could
go back and and clarify
the difference between cpa and roas
strategies
yeah so cpa is cost per acquisition
and so you give google a set of
conversion data now conversions
anything you want to define it could be
a lead a website visit
someone calling you what not and so you
put the leads into google and then you
tell google
right i want to pay x for a lead i want
to pay
25 or 40 and then
google is going to say all right i'm
going to set bids for you
trying to get to be your 40 conversion
for any conversions you're using
and from a lead generation standpoint
that sounds pretty good right like if
someone fills out a form we want to pay
200 based upon our close rates but
when you think of a variable checkout
amount um e-commerce
right one checkout could be ten dollars
the next could be two thousand dollars
right so in this case you wouldn't want
to pay the same amount right you don't
want to pay the same for a ten dollar
check out as a two thousand dollar
checkout
so rawas is return on ad spend
i'm often referred to as a ratio like um
100 meaning you you're breaking even and
200
you're doubling what you put in those
investments and so return
ad spend takes into account how much you
spent and the
revenue right that it was it got back
and therefore is looking at bidding
based upon how much money your money is
making as opposed to a straight cost per
lead okay
um we have a couple of
questions about uh
what university graduates could expect
do you have an insight into what a
a fresher graduate might expect to earn
um just out of the box that is so
country dependent
um and it's region dependent right um
we i would say in the united states
a college grad based on where they go
in and blah blah blah um often 35
at the very low end to 50 000
um but then seeing someone
within two to three years at the 80 000
to 90 000 level is not uncommon in the
united states
okay and the other question is
what would the best
strategy be for a fresher graduate
to pursue further education in digital
marketing
the question is literally what is best
for fresher graduates to start an
offline or online course in india
what is the best place to start an
online or offline course in india
yeah for somebody who's just graduated
so if you've just graduated college
right
and you want refresh so if
right so that you've got college classes
where you take them like simply learn
right i mean they're they're in college
classes
and you have the working knowledge of
what's happening
right now right essentially um then
if you want more you could take you know
a google ad search or a bing ad cert but
you really could go get a job
you have people who go to traditional
colleges and they get a marketing degree
but that degree does not get into
how platforms work and the nuances
of managing stuff in that case like i
simply one course is of course a great
place to be
um before you before getting the job and
and getting the own cpu certification
which is becoming more recognized um so
is it gonna sort of depend did you get a
traditional degree that
is not include what happens today versus
you have one
what's going on today yeah
um ciala
asks a technical question which is when
a new ad group is created
and some of the keyword status showed
non-eligible low
search volume will that status change
over time yes so
low search volume means there's
generally under
30 to 35 impressions per month for the
exact match of that term
um a low search volume term can't
actually get impressions
um because it matches some broad thing
it is probably not a lot
if that term suddenly starts getting a
lot more impressions the low search
volume will disappear
okay and
so mula also asks if a search term
triggers the same or similar keywords in
more than one
ad group does google decide
for you which is the best ad to show
yes which this is where when you have a
keyword
that is you've got a group a and ad
group b
and the same search term can convert can
trigger either ad
right google now has ad serving control
there's an offer where you want to say
no no i want ad group a
to actually serve so you add a negative
keyword to add group b
to force google to show the correct one
otherwise they'll just sort of go back
and forth and how they show them
okay um i see that we've reached the end
of our hour
and um that's all the time we have for
questions we have a few other questions
in the chat
and q a but unfortunately we don't have
time to get
to them this time i apologize to
our attendees for that but um
i want to thank you brad for this
really excellent webinar i'm going to go
ahead and share my screen so that we can
complete the presentation
and we'll do that starting with a poll
and this poll is for the audience
to ask
what digital marketing skills are you
most interested in learning
um we've been talking today
about ppc marketing and uh
keyword and ad strategies
and there's a number of other
disciplines within digital marketing
and then um when are you
planning to start that journey
and i certainly hope we included the
second question but i don't know if we
did
yeah i don't see it in the poll steward
it's not on my screen fyi all right
in the interest of time we'll skip over
that one but um here is result
and seo
is probably the most popular answer but
it goes across the board
it's a pretty even distribution a lot of
people interested in multiple
disciplines which is great
and what i'll mention is that and i've
dropped it into the chat
and the q a windows
we are offering discounts for today's
attendees
so for attending this webinar you will
be able to get
a 20 off discount on our postgraduate
program
in digital marketing which is in
partnership with purdue university
um and
you'll also be able to get a 30 off
discount if you choose to do digital
marketing master's programs
we have two levels associate and then
the higher level specialist
um you will receive an email after
today's webinar probably tomorrow
that includes links to these programs
and the
discount codes so don't worry if you've
missed the link in the chat
however you can go to simply learn's
website and
look at the course pages i will mention
what the purdue university
postgraduate program in digital
marketing looks like we co-created it
with facebook
it contains content from harvard
business publishing it's a six-month
program
that requires between five and ten hours
a week of
investment of time and it gets you
a purdue certification in digital
marketing as well as membership in the
alumni association the capstone project
at the end of the
program that you can use as a practical
example for your portfolio master
classes from purdue from facebook
and it covers a whole series of
courses in a integrated curriculum
so
i will
conclude with that and i want to say
thank you again to brad for
this excellent webinar um builds on
the past one and i've dropped the link
to that past twin a couple of times in
the chat and q
a so you can kind of go back and view
that one
and you'll receive a recording link for
this one
your email tomorrow so thank you brad
this is your linkedin information so
people can follow up with you
yep all right well thank you for hosting
us to it and thank you everyone for
attending today
wonderful and
we have our next webinar next week
wednesday
um a general career webinar on job
hunting strategies for tech
jobs with the head of human resources
from tonetag
vinay tribety so
we'll include a link to that in the
follow-up email for this webinar
and that concludes our
webinar for today so thank you all
so much for being here and thank you
brad
and we hope to see you next week in
another future
simply learn webinars
you